alright hello we're going to today we're
going to look at how to manage your
lives in the pepper panic saga game new
game by King a lot of people are playing
it's a lot of fun but if you're new to
the game you might not understand how to
send or receive lives and how to make
the most out of them so i just opened up
my game and I'm going to close that out
and you'll see when you first open the
game you'll have a lot of different
requests right now I have five lives so
i don't need the lives that my friends
have sent me you do want to send them
back so you keep lives coming in and out
but in the meat when you have a full
life you can't have more than five so
you don't want to do that so we'll
usually what I do is I go through when I
first sign in and send people who need
lives back you can see I've got some
plus three boosters that people have
sent me you can collect those if you
want I don't use them so i just closed
those out but you see outset i'll send
all my friends who need help you know
with tickets to get to the next stage
and lives you'll see sometimes whenever
you have new friends the first time you
send them something from the gift
they'll they'll be a pop-up it's just
that it's just making sure that you
don't want them to ask you each time you
send so it's only that little tick boxes
kaz a tick there you won't get that pop
up anymore and if you scroll down you'll
see there's lots of lots of requests
alright so now that I've collected some
tickets and set my friends some labs
you'll see that there's a blue envelope
up at the top each time you click on
that that's going to open it up and it's
going to show you all those same
requests that you have now the problem
is if you don't collect them and you
close the game out and reopen it well
then you're not going to be able to all
those gifts that are in your your
messages right now will disappear so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to I'm
going to pause the video I'm going to
play off some some some lives and then
I'm going to come back and I'm going to
explain to you how you can get the most
lives without losing them each time and
just some basic practices of how to you
know keep lobs coming in and out so in
one second all right so now you see I
played off a couple lives and I'm down
to two lives and it's going to be 26
minutes until I naturally get some more
so I'm going to do is I'm going to go to
my messages and I'm going to collect and
you'll see the number goes up and I
usually collect the four and then close
it again that way my timer will continue
to run that can come in handy if you're
closer you know to getting another life
for free that'll save you some more year
and your message is what I'm going to do
now is I'm going to collect the rest of
my lives
and show you that now you'll see that
the envelope is gone and I don't have
any more pending requests so generally
every single time I quit the game and I
know I'm not going to play for a while
I'll go through and i'll send all those
back that helps out your friends and
that also helps to make sure that you'll
have more lives sent to you when your
friends log into the game so that's a
good practice you know if you send
requests to your friends a lot you know
you want to send back as well that's
just you know part of being a friend and
a game like this and I'm gonna reload
the game and i'll show you how things
have changed
pepper panic is it works the same as all
the other games that that King has if
you if you've never played those you
know this was probably new information
if not it's just a reminder of how that
you know the best way to make sure you
have the most lives this is just a send
lives to them when they when you first
open up I usually always do that because
that's that's helpful and you'll see now
that since i restarted the game i have a
new set of lives and requests from
friends so the same way i'll just cut
people out and now i got three saved i
can play again i got my tickets to move
on to the next set of levels so at this
point i would just play on collect those
three either when I need them or
whenever I am ready to stop playing and
then the next time I sign into the game
will have more lives wait for me again
so this was just a basic video hopefully
this helps out gives you an idea of how
you you know you don't want to be the
guy who's always sending requests all
the time but not sending them back or
just collecting them and not you know
wasting the ones that you have if you do
it like the way I showed you then you'll
you'll constantly have lives coming in
and out as long as you have friends if
you need friends for the game we have a
add me group I would recommend joining
that those are people who play this game
specifically and are pretty active and
always helping out so if you add those
guys to your to your friend list you
know you'll have a pretty good amount of
lives coming in it's mentioned in the
About section below the video so just go
ahead and click on that link if you need
more friends and hope this is helpful
leave comments visit our site you know
wwp pepper panic tips calm and leave us
comments and let us know what you need
to help you play the game better thanks